[موسيقى]
غرق الآلاف من البحارة
قلبي حقًا لهم
قال تشرشل
إنها كانت واحدة من أسوأ الرحلات في
العالم وكما أقول إنني أحترمهم تمامًا
[موسيقى]
، لذلك يجب أن نقدم
مهما كانت المساعدة التي يمكننا
تقديمها لروسيا وللشعب الروسي ،
فقد تم تلقيها دائمًا بشكل جيد في بعض
الأماكن التي كانوا يتضورون جوعاً فيها
جوعاً حتى الموت ،
وكنت قد ذهبت إلى مقبرة
حيث توجد أكوام من التراب حيث
مات السكان المحليون ودُفنوا نوعًا ما
إنهم ليسوا
أسماء ، إنهم مجرد أرقام ،
لقد قُتل 27 مليون روسي
خلال الحرب وبدون تضحياتهم
وتضحية هذه
القوافل الروسية ، لم تكن الحرب لتنتصر أبدًا ،
والندم الوحيد الذي شعرت به
هو أنني لم أفعل ذلك.  عندما أتحدث الروسية ،
سأكون سعيدًا
جدًا بالرد على أي رسائل
ترغب في إرسالها ،
لذلك نأمل فقط ونصلي هناك دائمًا
[موسيقى]
سلام